[Applause]
really bizarre that you were bringing
that up right now okay welcome back I'm
sorry I'm just in love and having the
most fun um I am feeling OMG for QVC
right now because we are teaming up with
them to share the merriest hostings
items for your next holiday gathering
and joining me is a true QVC Legend
alberty
poage thank you
alberty yes Drew alberty propage I mean
you are literally the king oh I don't
know about that but you know what I will
tell you this right now we are the kings
of gift giving and I've got some of the
best ideas for you and for everybody out
there whether you're hosting a party or
thinking about picking the perfect gift
for a host well show us everything and
one of the reasons I've always loved QVC
and like just been a fan of the channel
is because you guys are storytellers
when we as like consumers go out and we
see something we just see an item
there's like a whole story there there
are functions to it that you just don't
even know you need someone to like
direct you and I think QVC does
something very special well we also try
and inspire you right so here's the
thing if you're hosting a party this
holiday season what's the number one
thing you need at the party music music
right by the way I was hoping I got that
right yes okay I was like you totally
did well how about this your old
cassettes your old CDs we all have them
well you can play this on the studa
baker cassette CD player but it also has
Bluetooth which is really great so if
you're streaming songs from your Spotify
or your Apple music or whatever it is
that you love so much you can do that as
well and you set the mood for the party
and it looks really cool oh it's
everything yeah it's everything it's
everything all in one and of course it's
portable and it's not too big and and it
has a very pretty aesthetic it is it is
well come on over here speaking of
pretty and aesthetic right we need
gorgeous lighting for a holiday party
but also all year round and nothing is
more beautiful than candle light and
luminara does it without any of the soot
ever having to light a candle or have an
open flame in your house this is a set
of five that we have right now at QVC
which is awesome because it's basically
half off a set of five but and here's
what's great right you've got all
different heights yes so you can create
a beautiful environment a moment and it
actually looks like real candle light
yeah it does because of the flicker
lumaro these candles you might remember
them if you've ever been down to that
Haunted Mansion at the world's happiest
place on Earth you might have seen this
type of flicker because they were the
ones that actually created that
technology no way see that's what I'm
telling you yeah storytelling brings us
in mhm that is such a cool piece of
information here's a great story about
this too when you go to QVC we have all
the color choices that you don't find in
a lot of stores with doors colors yeah
so we've got everything for your home
decor whether it's for your bedroom your
family room your living room also very
safe with kids very economical they not
wasting anything have a th000 hours of
battery life cuz I always forget to turn
those
off it's true well they've got timer
functions too so we got covered you
never even have to turn no they don't
yeah they do thank you all right so now
the last thing that you need for a party
right you need great
food cheesecake I heard you love
cheesecake my number one favorite
dessert is cheesecake so we brought you
the number one cheesecake from New York
we love this brand um it's the New York
original style cheesecake on the inside
but what they do for us at QVC check
this out they turned it into a Christmas
tree so that now you have a festive
decorative look and it's covered in
chocolate ganache you've got all the red
and green sprinkles that are cut out
like Christmas trees and when you bite
into it the room is filled with ooze and
a
up it's rich and it's decadent and it
can be shared by a whole group of people
at a party it is so good it really is
the best it's an iconic New York
institution oh they've been doing it for
over 75 years well Alberti previously is
a One-Stop shop for all your holiday
needs this year and they're hosting a
gift athon event this weekend December
8th through 10th for the best products
of the Season at the best deals and to
celebrate we're actually sending our
studio audience home thank you so much
for doing this with us a $100 gift card
from QVC for
everyone in the audience
thank you to QVC for doing this with us
because I hope everyone in the audience
takes care of themselves or a loved one
and um thank you for allowing us to do
that on this show for everybody well
thank you so much for inviting us onto
your show well alberty I like want
another date can we do this again
anytime you want thank I'll
be okay everybody we'll be right
back thank
you
[Music]
yeah